this guy how crazy he is i was i was
given a eulogy
for the lady used to be the manager of
the band i played and i'm giving a
eulogy up there and i look out
in the church you see him and they're
[ __ ] rough like this with his arm
around my daughter
that's awesome with a big smile on his
face
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
gentlemen the holidays came early
because manscaped the leading man's
hygiene brand has launched new products
all new ultra premium body wash and a
two in one shampoo and conditioner
it's time to give yourself the gift of
beautiful skin hair and balls this
holiday season i guarantee your hygiene
routine will never be the same this is
what i like about manscape is
anybody would be happy just treating
your webbles you know to a nice close
shave but to do hair and body wash and
conditioner they're stepping it up so go
to manscape.com
omg high for 20 off and free shipping
make sure you're feeling and smelling
prepared for a little action
under the mistletoe because i know my
wheels i always check my
uh levels at the end of the day and
since i've been using manscape
uh i'm gonna say i'm a little upset that
i don't have as much to smell as i used
to
okay ever pull into the driveway after a
trip to the grocery store only to
realize you forgot the one key
ingredient for your dinner
now you have options get the groceries
you need or a backup meal from your
favorite local restaurant delivered with
doordash for a limited time our
listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees for the first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code omgh
download the doordash app and enter code
omghi for this special deal
oh right after you know when you were
filming and [ __ ] got [ __ ] up i hadn't
been tested or whatever
yeah yeah well
i didn't go with you i took off that day
and it worked out it worked out great
because i got a a good partner of mine
we worked radio car
back in the 70s together
and a radio car yeah you the guy's
crazier than the [ __ ] house mouse got a
great
sense of humor
about three months ago he got diagnosed
with uh
the [ __ ] the stage four lung cancer and
a couple of spots hit his kidneys so i
told the wife i said hey i got this week
off george ain't doing it i'm not going
with george
see you later i took off to go visit him
and have a suit how's he doing he's
doing all right he's got a great outlook
on life
he sits here and he tells me what's his
own look i grant wants to know yeah he
he sits here and he tells me
first off he's going to va and he asked
me for advice he says hey you know i can
go to the city hall i said [ __ ] it he
lives in havasu
so he's going to the va out now
in phoenix and i said
wrong city of hope has every [ __ ]
thing you got a brother that lives right
here
i said
at least consult with him
wow so that's what that's what he did he
got all his testing done through the va
then they wired everything the city of
hope he came down here for consultation
they told him
i said how'd it go this was good good
they said
va is doing everything that they would
be doing he says they concur they're not
going to operate on any of it they think
they can shrink it with medication grab
that mic
they think they can uh shrink the tumors
of medication
give you three to seven years three to
ten years
of life which one does he want he says
i'll take six what's his answer he said
i just told him he said [ __ ] it i'll
take six you see i knew to ask yeah that
was good that was good and then he said
to show you a sense of humor he says hey
this was just last month i was going
through this heart procedure look in my
heart he says gil
he said i know you keep playing it down
he said but i know what it is and i know
you know that it's dangerous you know
one wrong move and they could [ __ ] you
up and i said yeah but i don't look at
it like that he says well
just
in case preparation he says if if you go
south is it gonna upset you if i'm
sitting at your services next to your
wife he said i just want to sit next to
her
well
you can sit next to her just don't
invite your [ __ ] third grade
girlfriend
this guy how crazy he is i was i was
given a eulogy
for the lady used to be the manager of
the band i played and i'm giving a
eulogy up there and i look out
in the church you see him and they're
[ __ ] rough like this with his arm
around my daughter
that's awesome with a big smile on his
face
yeah he's he's nuts and it was
i went down to see him how come some
dudes have personalities like that and
some guys don't what do you think that
is i i have no idea is it where you come
from is it is it in your blood are guys
meant to
be quiet and some dudes you know are
quiet some guys are funny all the time
some guys you know are hard to make
friends with
you know like if you say oh this guy man
he's cold when you meet him and then
when you get to know him he's really a
good guy but they're consistent what
what is that in somebody's
i know their psyche and their family
psyche i don't know because i'm
different than my sisters and
you know
in my family my dad was very funny he
was a humorous guy yeah and uh ralph
uh just
the environment the people hanging
around with you know ralph's good
yeah
he said he's different doing it for a
living but he's the life of the party
you know
he sits there and
nothing was sacred not even his mom he'd
make fun of his mom you know
yeah
but nothing
serious all very light spirited no no i
mean you know sometimes people get mad
if you make a joke in uh
in a tough situation totally you know
they think it's like what did they say
what how did you say that
uh it's nothing is sacred yeah but
ultimately
i think that
you know you got to uh
enjoy enjoy yourself but you know some
people are very sensitive you know like
like when i was going to get my surgery
you know ann was already having surgery
and then
you know the lady came in
with me and she said uh you know i i
think it's you know it's quite a gift
you know
what your wife is doing doing for you
and i said uh you know i said well you
know you should see where she lives
that lady didn't think that was funny
yeah you know you got to look for the i
i don't look for the negative side of
anything everything is my glass is half
full versus half empty and that's where
ralph is you know
we're all going we're all going
somewhere you want to go shy or you want
to go
[ __ ] loud
you want to go quietly
or you want to go where people say who
that guy man the god okay remember when
we met yes remember the guy that was
sitting with us that didn't really say
anything [ __ ] i don't
well that guy yeah i mean what how do
you want them to describe you yeah you
know you know on on
instagram i just look at instagram all
the time and the one thing about the
iphone is it tells you how much of your
life you're [ __ ] wasting looking at
your phone and how much time you're
wasting looking instagram in the last
two or three months hardly anything at
all at all
and i and i feel more connected to
um i wouldn't say i do more [ __ ] during
the day but i feel more connected to
just not wasting my time looking at my
phone
all the time when i'm by myself
so i think for me you know it's helped
me you know just kind of be
okay with just [ __ ] not always being
on the phone man i used to jump into the
phone and the ipad
uh just
as a place that was safe to me
because that's when my mother-in-law was
there yeah
well yeah so it just it was my safe zone
yeah go in there and pay attention to
anything and right and that was it
uh now
[ __ ] i i don't i don't use it as much
uh as i used to there's yeah you know
you go over there and see your friends
and stuff and you go to the bf you know
and and uh
there's something to that man to doing
[ __ ] that
you know uh um requires interaction
because you know we're the type of
person that would go to the room and be
in there and just be in there on this or
doing something like you know i would
say that you know in the beginning
things used to bother me more like this
we're almost like you know i was coming
to the end of this year but not once
have i
came over here and said man i don't want
to [ __ ] go over there which is one of
the reasons why when people ask me if
you did a podcast would you do a podcast
this and that and i would always be like
yeah but i grew up disinterested with
stuff but but this thing
uh is something that i have not once
said i'm like today i got [ __ ] lost
i'm from here
but how come people you know
in in
in my day in school there's a high
school over here this thing
somebody had like maybe a girl had one
thing
on her body that you know if somebody
wasn't attractive that they had a big
death out or like a a fat ass
everybody i don't know how everybody got
has ass now like you know
going through the airports like you
would see a girl probably had a fat ass
like one out of ten
and now
[ __ ] nine out of ten
man what did genetically what is it what
the [ __ ] where'd all these [ __ ]
cuddle come from
and they think it's i'm just grateful
that they they think it's beautiful
listen my aunts had fat asses i didn't
think i used to run in front of him so
i'd have to walk behind him i didn't
think any of him any of our fat ass is
uh
is interactive and and i
i just love people i i do
i keep tabs with some of my wife's
friends that were she was best friend i
called him up hey just checking on you
what are you doing you know how's it
going
and
she don't get mad at that no no no
she called her
[ __ ]
i remember she called her and uh
i was in new mexico lecture and she
called me and said okay what's going on
prolardy told me and there were problems
in river city between pearl and myself
she was
all i'm telling you and she was divorced
and she just said
i don't know anything about
what the problems are you know and i
have nothing about i know what she's
accusing you of
she said but i just told her
you know what
you've got a good man
and he says you've never worked you've
never paid for anything you don't know
what it's like to go home
go out and go to work for eight hours
come back and then have to cook for the
family and do the laundry and do this
and do that
says he's a good guy you know you better
rethink everything that you're doing
and she says in you gil
i don't know whether you did or whether
you didn't and it's none of my business
she says but if you did
you better not ever say you did because
it'll never
nothing will ever happen
good out of it and so i keep in touch
with her and she she loves my wife and
and she's just a friend they went to
high school together and
she was good she was
we probably stay in touch because my
composite is family and her very close
yeah so i that's how i still
uh reach out and her dad
her dad loved us and he was in the army
and he was a world war ii veteran
and so everything's gone good
it doesn't bother me
she's good and my wife on the other hand
it's tough to be
long-time friends she's an introvert my
wife is an introvert
you know she
doesn't uh
socialize you know she doesn't reach out
to many people everything is
all close family you know and so there's
more and she's always been like that
right yes yeah yes it's hard to it's
hard to
you know they say you can't change
horses in midstream and a lot of times
you know some people do change behavior
um
but it's really hard man and it doesn't
seem like it would be that hard if
somebody would say just get up one time
and go look outside one day with
somebody my grandma hated to go outside
i was like just get up and go outside ah
it's right there just open the door and
[ __ ] go outside my wife
initially
was hesitant was a little reluctant
simple invitation
to a
breast cancer fundraiser right
right and she's
uh
you know she really didn't right because
she's an introvert doesn't want to go
out and mingle with anybody she's like a
lot of people lack of self-confidence
in her
and i said dear
the invitation has been extended
i'd like to go yeah and she says okay
okay we'll go
and so
on the way up there
i'm sitting there saying
dear
whoever thought that you and i two
mexicans from pico would be in a car on
the way to the beverly hills hotel to be
sitting in the table of the guests of
george lopez
and then she starts oh yeah and then she
started getting a little nervous and we
got there it's a beautiful place yeah
but yet
she had a beautiful we had a good time
we had a good time that night huh yeah
we did she had a beautiful times happy
talks about it just so excited
and she's never
gotten as close to anybody and as close
as can be
she really loves you you know george is
so nice and hey say hi to george yeah
good you know and and so it was fun it
was good to see you guys and and uh are
you guys going to take that trip
yeah we you need to give me some kind of
paperwork oh yeah yeah you know give me
the give me the paperwork we got to fill
it out and send it in and all right yes
yeah i got him a trip to um
to mexico yeah oh yeah yeah oh awesome
yeah do you know when or is it whatever
you want no you gotta fill in like i i
bought one that night for the dodgers i
gotta send in paperwork and they'll give
me they'll send me the dates that are
available
and uh
and for constants too i got concepts of
trip too huh
and the last thing
was uh
we were just talking
yesterday because i'm trying to plan our
50th wedding anniversary
was last year but it was during the
covet thing yeah oh yeah so i mean
the year prior we had already figured
out i know this will shock you
i was going to have something at
stephen's steakhouse a big blown out
15th wedding anniversary what at the
stephens i'm talking jimmy jimmy's oh
yeah we'll blow this one out this isn't
going to be a regular this it's going to
be the best kill
and so
it's all said and done and then covet
hit so it's all canceled
so i'm talking to her the other day and
i and i'm telling her hey dear you know
it's the 51st is coming up
we didn't do anything last year
although it was the best anniversary
we've ever had exactly what my kids did
and so
this one
you know makeup you have any idea what
you want to do
and so we discussed it a little bit
and then this morning i just remind her
i said hey there you know you got all
these
me these plans
uh
she like george doesn't want to go to
stevens this year you know she's you
know
she's always going to see you know i
said well if we went to stephen invited
a bunch of people well she's not like me
she goes there all the time and she's
like i don't want to [ __ ] go here
anymore i've never gone there yet but i
know about it but but you see that
qinghao man we're going to have the same
fundraiser here as i had you know when
when uh when i fell and they had a
welcome back party in the same place you
can't have all the parties at the same
place so but i could have it there
and i could have it nice i could invite
a bunch of people like do a lot of stuff
so she says no
what about the mission inn
in riverside oh now that's beautiful
haunted beautiful in it they have
christmas decorations oh yeah yeah yeah
beautiful they have a nice restaurant
and i said okay well one time i had a
behind the parking lot
in ballet
the guys say you can see
the head of the microphone right there
by the line
don't worry about it
good
hey it wasn't during the winter because
it gets cold i know it was during the
only i only i only take out my photo
during the season
so but it's a beautiful place yeah it
was so i said okay if that's what you
want to do we'll go there but we have to
cut the numbers down
you know over there because it's not
that big you know what you got to do oh
yeah yeah and so
then this morning i told her i said hey
we can't do [ __ ] for our anniversary our
anniversary is the day after christmas
oh
we can't do [ __ ] this year for
anniversary because we just got
confirmation on the 21st of december
that's when they've scheduled my
daughter to give her kidney
to my knees yeah damn so
we forgot i said we're not going to be
able to go out and party and have me
take care of her you know whatever she
needs
and even if she doesn't need a bunch of
care i mean we can't go out and have a
good time with her laid up you know that
she's part of this whole cha-cha
so she just right away went into mommy
mode and said
that's right no and i'm gonna have to be
baking food i'm gonna well listen i had
a kitty transplant and i was upstairs
the [ __ ] world went on without me
[ __ ] around so
you might be able to slide out for a
little while and come back oh i know i
can't i already told her i said so see
you're going to be taking care of your
daughter you'll be cooking doing all
that [ __ ] i'll go out by myself have a
good time i'll party for both of us
good that's good
so you're 51 years 51 what two years the
day after christmas 51 years
is there a secret 10 15 75 dog years
i mean even more than that right
230 earthworm years
is there a secret to a long-lasting
marriage
yeah yeah
pearl
i think it's the other i think it's the
person yeah but you know when when when
trust or respect
or
you say decency or or even knowing when
to
be funny and when not to be funny like
you know
you get to a point where you can be a
little bit disrespectful on a regular
basis but you don't realize it's
disrespectful to somebody because it's
been so long but there has to remain
like a like a watermark you can't go
below the
below to a certain point you know and
especially in
in public
personally oh yeah where you might say
something go oh that was kind of mean
and i know he says that all the time
that that's never like in a relationship
that never goes that never works she was
disappointed
one year we were on a cruise
and with a bunch of friends we're on
this seven day cruise and
you know they have the nights you dress
up to go to dinner it's a
tuxedo or a suit whatever you want to
so i'd been on a ship all day and they
were giving away these souvenir glasses
with every drink
they were nice glasses i said i want to
take a bunch of these home to my kids
i'm thinking of my kids and the more i
drank i need more glasses i need more
so then i'm thoroughly vavoso yeah i go
up to my room and my wife's getting
ready for dinner and she says hey gil
why don't you just stay in the room
we'll go to dinner and you you and i
will go out
you and i will go out later and yeah
have some dinner i said all right
you guys she said i said but i really
want to go she said no no no no please
just stay here
i said okay
all right i get it
i understand
i remember i was wearing white shorts
and i had a red t-shirt that said
instead of coca-cola it said kome kaka
which looked just like coca-cola i
remember those shirts so i walked into
the dining room she went to eat and get
one of those at ah-ha
yeah so i walk into the dining room
everybody's there all dressed up to the
tents i walk in and my commander here
are telling my wife
he's back
i've been a [ __ ] captain kangaroo in
his white shorts
how was this [ __ ] campana swinging
left and right
and so
i was back was right
and uh
that was it
she got up she walked out
walked up to me
and she says come on
and she put her arm into my arm
and i just said
i know
this was wrong
yes let's go i said okay i'm sorry this
was wrong
and she took me back to the room and i
went back no fight no nothing
i thought it was funny but
evidently she didn't think what people
was that what's that did you know all
those people yeah yeah yeah we were in a
large group they thought it was funny
and just my wife didn't think it was
funny and were there were there
repercussions like the next day or
afterwards not at all
not at all it's a beautiful thing you
guys should see she
let it go she's a little bit disgusted
but you know and and you're saying that
like i can't remember how many times i
didn't well i can't remember every time
but i i
most of the time
i didn't want to go anywhere
uh i still remember when when somebody
used to almost make me go i i [ __ ]
didn't want to go man like i was like
hey i don't want to go and i'll tell you
i don't want to go don't make me go and
then they make you go so there's a
balance in things of like okay you don't
have to go to this
don't worry about it you know i'd like
you to go to this but you don't have to
go to that but there has to be i think a
balance in a relationship of saying like
you know that's cool don't worry about
it but i need i'll let you not go to
this one but i'm gonna need you for this
one because this is more important than
that one it i talked her into i didn't
talk to her i i asked her the
documentary which i thought she did an
excellent job yes she did and and now
that you say that it's not something she
would have been comfortable with is
sitting in front of
a camera and talking just her giving the
information no she wasn't and she didn't
want to do it and i said dear i can't
make you do it i'm asking you to do it
because i think there's so much it's
important for you
to put that out there for other wives
yes to see what
they're going through i said it's going
to be beneficial not only will it make
the documentary better but it'll it'll
help people
and let them see i think it humanized
you too and and so
she agreed to do it she was scared to
death we got up there she's nervous i
said
tiller is good
he's just gonna sit you down and they'll
start talking to you yeah and it'll come
out and i'll be i was in the room right
next to her i was monitoring everything
and uh she held back she fought back the
emotional side she fought back tears yep
she laughed a little
with the three goals that i had the one
was to dump her she said
and that one didn't work or whatever
yeah yeah
so she was really good and then
well it showed a side of of you that was
not about the detective side sure your
father her
uh your friends
you know uh um
pumpkin you know who the ladies name
pumpkin pauline there you go uh that
that it it um
it showed a a side story to your life
that that humanized you and and
made it not just about the search for
some you know notorious guy but also
uh the people affected by something like
that
yeah
i think that's why that's why those
things are
are
um you know ben baller i saw ben baller
today he wants to come on the podcast
but he said how excited he was to to sit
with you at the tournament and talk to
you because he remembers at that time
and he was like man i can't remember
that that was my man right there like i
love that guy and uh i said that's you
know that's that of it i just saw him
now ben
uh
hernandez that is
ben you said ben baller
dude that we play golf with him okay no
not him i i saw ben hernandez ben ben
bray yeah i just saw him i've seen the
movie
and and i'm not ashamed to tell you i've
seen the movie at least a half a dozen
times and it makes me tear up every time
uh
mcfarland
it's a movie about the mexicans that
were running for
cross country i'm supposed to be in that
movie and he was in the guy the store he
was oh yeah
and the lady hey you'd have been good
the owner so you'd be getting slim jibs
out
hey here you'd smell this you'll [ __ ]
run
i met the lady first and then she didn't
put me in there i thought i'm gonna
nicky somebody or somebody but i didn't
get that i met her first
and then she replaced me with somebody
he was a tough dad he was a tough dad in
the movie
and i'm watching last night with my son
and my wife and i said
hey that's ben hernandez that's ben bray
and i said look it up because it was a
quick what part did he have he was the
father one of the the fastest run on the
floor who took my part
uh the guy in the store some
some chino i don't know not a chino a
mexican guy older guy i don't know his
name i've seen him before and other
stuff
but what's that guy from what did
valente from my show play
he was just one of the he's one of the
best yeah he was one of the dads funny
that that lady yeah all right well
you know
is it a good movie yeah what it didn't
do well
if you weren't a latino
it wouldn't do well that's problem with
our movies nobody wants to see them so
if you're not latino these are a group
of guys that were from the piscas
you know that
this white coach went over there and
started training them got him to run and
got him to do this
and they ended up being the state champs
first time ever and they won it several
times after that
and there was an opportunity for him
to leave the school to go to a rich
school yeah with more equipment more
money more everything
safer community
and he turned it all down to stay right
there where the guys from uh in real
life were in the movies in real life
they got that
thing on instagram song going out you
see guys working on something
you see the crab that's eating corn
while it's being was being cooked in the
pot oh my god i saw that yesterday yeah
that's a bummer
the motherfucker's the crab is in the
pot getting cooked
and there's some corn in there by them
and he's picking the corn and eating
them while he's [ __ ] being boiled no
yeah
right yeah i'll see if i can find it
that was uh i saw that going around
he's talk about crabs in the barrel that
he's [ __ ] eating corn as he's going
out
it's a man you ever see the one where
the where the
crab was in the pot
and of hot water they put him in and he
jumped out and turned the stove off no
jumps out if this [ __ ] claws crawls
over turns the [ __ ] stove off it
looks like the guy said you care okay
[ __ ]
turn it off
all right what else do i have oh holy
[ __ ] i found it yeah one sec
you talked to that dude ak-47 that
brother yeah i hit him up today
maybe that one i know that one look
there's a thing you turn the stove off
he turned the stove off i'll grab that
link i'll include it in the show notes
[ __ ]
so um
that's hilarious what do you think what
happened like in kyle ridden houses
rittenhouse's
case you know i i tried to explain to
the wife
that all we ever see here all anybody
ever sees is what the news once put out
and you don't know if they're putting
out everything
or something less and you don't know i'm
i'm
so extremely happy that he didn't kill
two black people african-americans
because then there would have been
rioting right away because the white guy
got offered after killing the blacks
i got an email and not an email i uh
yeah it was
a buddy of mine sent me this thing and
it says
wow i didn't know this
and msnbc never put it out
and it's a list of things about that
particular case
like the kid the gas station where all
this [ __ ] started at
belonged to his grandparents
and he was protecting his grandparents
before he got jumped and started getting
chased
he was 17 years old and it was perfectly
legal in their state
for him to possess
a weapon
he got he started getting his ass kicked
and he's down on the ground they hit him
in the head with this uh
skateboard
and
they were kicking him when he's a when
he well this was defense theory he
didn't get hit in this [ __ ] escape
with escape over handing out free hugs
he's walking down the middle of the
street with two weapons
and
i think people are afraid
around him right you can see people
around him kind of like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing i'd be afraid if i saw
anybody i don't care who's a cop or not
i'd be afraid of anybody walking around
with a gun
but if we don't know the entire story
and we don't know
exactly what the jury heard
and his defense attorney said had he not
taken a stand
they probably would have lost the case
because the prosecution's putting forth
a good
day before day before they rested
the prosecution which tells me
what are they really doing
who's running the show they dropped one
of the charges against him
because they didn't know
they charged him with minor possession
of a gun
the prosecutors didn't even know that
that's not a violation of law where
they're at
so he was perfectly legal in possession
okay so yeah so that's why they dropped
that that that's why they dropped that
one charge so we only know what the news
is giving us
those jurors i had to tell my wife
my wife made fun of him
the the crying on the stand for crying i
understand
look at these dry crap what a good actor
you know he's trying to do that man how
phony you know he had a
but yet they said when they interviewed
some of the jurors
it was his testimony that won them over
so i don't know how real it was we only
know what the news media is
feeding us i know what it's like
as an investigator there were homicides
and
officer-involved shootings
so i know how difficult it is
you know to get a prosecution
successfully convict getting a suspect
successfully convicted unless you got
all the right answers but they threw the
best they had in front of the jury and
the jury said
there's not enough and it wasn't because
he was white i'm glad the suspect in
this case wasn't black
because if theta convicted him they're
only convicting him because he's black
and the white guys got killed that's why
they're going after him well
and and i just don't know enough so i
can't say
he shouldn't have been convicted he
should have been convicted i know i was
listening uh
uh
a man that i really
thoroughly enjoyed his company what is
that
and uh
am i on the thing [ __ ] hey what
you what are you doing
i'm doing my podcast look
there's my cop right there
hey what's up deal i was just about to
drop your name
i was just about to drop your name how
you doing
i'm doing great y'all sound great
hey that [ __ ] beard got white
as [ __ ]
[Applause]
has your dog bit anybody today
i want dl to know deal i want you to
know from me i tell everybody how good
you were to me out on a golf course it's
a day that i'll never forget primarily
because of you
man yeah but he also says that you you
said you didn't like cops oh yeah i did
i i laughed at that he didn't like most
cops matter of fact i hate most
[ __ ] cops and i i remember that
that was true and
hey all it did was make me laugh i don't
give a [ __ ] about the other ones you did
you don't hate me
i think we found the slogan for
recruiting officers
i don't hate all [ __ ] cops join
[Laughter]
now you good are you staying out there
for the holidays
your grandkids are grown fast though
yeah yeah oh man i only got one yeah no
i know yeah grandkid
congratulations on the thing
congratulations on your mind oh thank
you yeah i'm gonna put your ass to work
too and put your ass to work there
good
let's do it
all right man i love you brother
okay happy thanksgiving happy
thanksgiving thanks for driving back
all right
so do you actually accidentally call him
no i think they were trying to do uh
one of my one of the guys in that circle
is having an issue with someone who
may have been
using funds that weren't necessarily all
his so one of the guys was looking for
some guidance there and i think he tried
to
facetime the whole group and then i i
tried to turn it off it was dl oh yeah
have dry skin ashy skin
well you're in luck manscape new
products includes the ultra premium body
wash
this 16 ounce aluminum bottle with a
pump top is infused with aloe vera and
sea salt to keep your skin feeling clean
fresh and moisturized
add their new 2.1 shampoo
and conditioner to your manscaped
arsenal
the two in one shampoo conditioner have
key ingredients with benefits that
include
sea kelp extract
coconut water
saw palmetto
take care of your hairs fellas
don't forget about your flagship about
their flagship product the lawnmower 4-0
the electric trimmer has proprietary
advanced skin safe technology so this
trimmer reduces cuts on your nuts
it's also waterproof so you can use it
in the shower that's a big deal you know
i think that
ladies appreciate somebody
that takes care down there that was the
name of my first show that i never sold
take care down there
get 20 off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
omghi that's 20 off with free shipping
that turns out to be quite a bit of
money at manscape.com omg hi clean up
your candy cane this year with manscape
imagine if you could blow yourself you'd
want to make sure down there yeah
why can't you what that's what i always
say what do you want to eat tonight
maybe you want a home-cooked favorite
but don't feel like going to the store
or you want something exciting new but
it would be great to stay in tonight
doordash connects you with everything
you want whenever and however you want
it
get what you want to eat right now and
right to your door with doordash along
with restaurants you love you can now
get groceries and other essential items
delivered
with doordash get drinks snacks and
other household items
in under an hour
they're expanding their their role here
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter the
code
omghi that's 25 off up to a 10 value and
zero delivery fees for your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter omghi
don't forget that's code omghi for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
which means
depends how your [ __ ] attitude is
when you call
if you have respect they'll give it to
you but if you're like hey you don't say
please those are the terms apply that's
what i think
so i was about to say dl and and i
started to say that perception is
reality to the perceiver
and dl was very vocal yeah about
hey this guy shouldn't have got off
so there is nothing that is going to
change dl's mind nor would i ever try to
and i i had a case
where
it was in the city of paramount
railroad tracks some transit jumped
jumped the back fence came in the house
armed with a knife
the mexican family on the inside he had
his wife two kids he's here he could
hear noise at the back door he goes to
the kitchen goes to open the back door
and here's this transit
now coming at him with a knife
fortunately when he heard all the noise
he grabbed a gun
because he's by the railroad tracks
and the guy comes at him with a knife
and bam bam bam he shoots him and the
guy's dead
and he falls right outside the door i
mean you can see where he was shot
inside he was able to get up he fell
outside the door dead so now we're
trying to identify this guy we identify
him while we're still there
i end up getting a call from the father
who's calling from like uh i i want to
say he was calling him georgia yeah and
he was an african-american black man
he's calling me up and he wants to know
what happened to his son
and i said his son was a transient yes
and i said sir i'm so sorry i
i i'll explain it as easy as i can
but it appears it's your son and i
didn't say anything negative about him i
said it appears that your son middle of
the night is trying to come into some
man's house
and shops were fired and your son
who did not live there who was trying to
break into the man's house and was
appeared to be armed with a knife was
shot and unfortunately he met his
untimely demise
and he says
yeah yeah
but i know how you cops are out there
you just shoot everybody it's out on the
news we all know about it and i said
well sir
no law enforcement were involved in this
this was the homeowner
he says yeah
he says
mexican just like you
you're all sticking together aren't you
i know how it is out there
i said sir i i really i'm so sorry
uh it doesn't appear that we're gonna do
anything you know we're gonna change
your mind over the phone right now
if you'll give us a few days i'll be
more than happy to meet with you in
person if you want to come out here
i will talk to you on the phone at
length whatever you'd like sir i don't
need to talk to you no more and then he
hung up
now that man
was convinced
that cops shoot anybody they want to and
get away with it out here and number two
because the family was mexican and i was
mexican i was going to cover up make
everything good
that was his perception of things and
nothing i would say or do is going to
change his mind
even though he didn't know all the facts
of the case because whatever we did to
investigate it whatever we documented
was not going to be believable in his
mind anyway
because cops were no good and mexican
stuck together
anybody that has a belief one way or the
other on any of these cases
without being without having first-hand
knowledge of the investigation
it's really tough but those are okay
we understand that those are like i
would say on the line
okay
you know those are kind of you know
those are kind of in that thing where
somebody's not there
what about
when
that cop was driving chasing somebody
and shot through his own windshield at
somebody that was running from him like
shot from the inside of his car through
his windshield
at somebody that was running
like you ever seen a cop shoot through
his own car
i saw it i've seen it before
and and it's you know
what you have to understand
is bullets go through glass and if
somebody's pointing a gun at me and not
the window's rolled up i'm shooting
right through the glass you know there's
always running there i got i get that
part of it uh i've seen
just on the internet you know i want to
say it was las vegas or yeah i'm looking
there's a thousand one in fact i mean
there's a thousand i mean there's a
thousand of them where the guy was
shooting through the window
and they got him uh i don't know
you know every instance every one of
those things is are based on their own
merits and every police department has
different and the most police department
you know in days of old when i was first
out there you know you could shoot at a
fleeing felon
the law said you could shoot at a
departmental policy said don't shoot at
a fleeing felon
you know unless you can articulate i
remember at the pomona fair
the pomona cops shot a guy
as he was running and they shot him in
the back
but
he had a gun in his hand and he had shot
and so now they're worried if we don't
get him somebody else is gonna get hurt
right so in that instance you know every
case runs on its own merits and if
you're of the mind that hey they're just
gonna lie well nothing you're gonna say
or do
is gonna change that opinion one way or
another
well you know there's so many i mean
with the internet and with the news the
way it is and the 24 hour cycle
every every shooting from every place
and social media you're going to see a a
a speck of the reality of the and make
your judgment on a 58-second clip
and and and i'm not here to profess that
all cops are
clean because i've had
uh i've had a cop work
that great cup unfortunately on you i
put a gun on you yeah fortunately here
locally uh nobody got hurt where
you know the cop shot him he was running
and but then he made up a story
you know after and i had to tell his
chief police because we were
investigating for local city
and i had to tell his chief hey
you know your boy's lying it doesn't fit
with the evidence
you know nothing's there he's documented
what his story is
and i remember at that time they had
their first black officer
and he's telling me he's giving me a
story and this guy's sweating bbs
and i said son we're going to stop what
i'm going to do is i'm going to put you
in my car we're going to take you out to
the scene
and
you're going to look at it because what
you're telling me
is going to get you an awful lot of
trouble and he said sir you don't
understand i'm the first black officer
in the history of this department and
i'm scared to death i said son
you don't do this right i'm going to
advise you your constitutional rights
right
so let's go out there and take a look
you take a look again because what
you're saying you thought you saw
isn't real it's impossible so we went
out there we came back we sat down and
said okay and he gave me the story and i
had physical evidence to back up
what was saying
that fortunately for that cop
for that
yeah the cop because he was a shoot
shooting at the fleeing suspect
you know nobody else got hurt
man
i mean other than other than the suspect
he got a bullet in the hand when he was
going over a fence
but hand out
so
that cop
ended up quitting
they sat on a six they sat on it for six
months they didn't file on him but he
lost his job lost everything else lost
his income
and he was just bad news
and we got a uh
i remember wanting a fire he did get
fired
uh
a cop
and he was a
white cop
and he shot and killed
mexican national
on new year's eve
and the first thing they did was they
instructed everybody going out on new
year's eve
stay out of the one ways is that my turn
to stay the [ __ ] going on with this i
turned mine off you got a chorus line in
here today
of course
i turned my phone off
but let's get this thing off here
is that a computer is that an ipad it's
an ipad
it's it's an ipad with one of those like
hard shell cubes right
is it is that like the apple one that it
comes with oh no it's an interesting
question
thanks siri it's uh how tiny is girls
paulo
[Laughter]
no information
what i've been trying to let it answer
before you turn it off
no i don't want to know how big my
follower was because it's small they'll
say palito
and so
this guy went out there they instructed
the cops that night
don't go down to the klingerman's
it was in south armani
because
everybody knows it's a bunch of
apartments in there new year's eve
there's gonna be a bunch of mexicans and
they're gonna be shooting in there not
shooting at each other yeah they're
gonna be shooting stay off the streets
don't go back there well he was a
one-man unit and he went down there man
knowing
that they're gonna do this he heard the
shots he went through the apartments he
saw some
mexicans drinking in the carport area
and he comes around he says all right
everybody freeze the guy with a gun
first thing he does is hey who's this
and he goes around yeah
he's got a gun in his hand
so
you can't justify you how do you get a
filing on that deputy
the guy had a guy was armed there'd been
shots fired
he turns around so now how do you
prosecute him
you can't because
he felt his
uh his life was in danger yeah but he he
he was told not to go to a place that he
knew that was going to probably be he
got fired yeah and that was it he did
get because you know what you know
that's going to be happening yeah
like you know we did a thing in los
angeles for i think kobe did it too
where
it was about shooting in the air at new
year's on new year's eve like those
bullets come down they sure do yeah and
people get i've had i've had a murder
like that well we called it a murder but
that's what it was and they can go
through roofs of houses and stuff right
just i don't know it went through this
guy's head real quick
yeah and you know he just shot up in the
air they're all having a party in the
backyard
and it it was up then
when these dudes start shooting
i think new year's eve they were shoot
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on last year
at night where people were shooting
these weapons like
you're just like man i i'd go inside i'd
go inside back in the 70s he tells to
get off the streets yeah on new year's
eve just go inside for 5-10 minutes you
know just get off the streets it's not
worth it you know everybody thinks that
because i guess of shows and tv shows or
you know um
superhero movies that you know you can
you know you think you could
withstand somebody looking at you or
holding a gun to you it's way [ __ ]
different in real life
when
somebody when somebody pulls a gun
in a store and says all right nobody
[ __ ] move you know and everybody's
like hey you're not going to shoot me
you know
the the
those games i think like those those
games that kids play have done a lot to
the sensor type size kids but also i
think it's giving kids a false sense of
like you think you know what it's like
to shoot somebody or be shot at or had a
gun pulled on you it's nothing like it
is on video games
right they haven't been
through
you know they need a reality check
because when we were growing up somebody
yelled at you you know you were
concerned you were frightened you did
you listen
and now
you tell somebody hey get your hands up
now [ __ ] you what are you gonna do shoot
me
you know and there's nothing more
fearful to a cop when you got a gun on
somebody which is deadly
and those guys don't want to do what
you're telling them and they give you
what is called passive resistance oh
come on you know come on this is
ridiculous
and they continue to move forward at you
you know so now you either have to
continue to move back and retreat
or just get ready for something you know
um
you know i i don't know the level of
training i think every police officer
has a different level of training but
when i was looking at youtube stuff
about police you know i was i think when
we first met fascinated on people that
were
impersonating police officers you know
but but also how difficult it is for a
police officer to to roll into a place
and then take a look at the surroundings
and figure out who's good and who's bad
now they separate people so there's a
they get a call i think i i don't know
what's what city it's in and there's a
guy back there his hands in his pockets
the cop comes around the corner goes hey
man take your hands out of your pockets
you know let's talk and the guy's
talking like pretty
level he's not out of his mind and he's
like you know i'm just here you know i'm
doing this thing in the cop he pulls a
gun out of his
out of his pocket he had it in his hand
and he kills that cop and that comp was
really kind of trying to be nice to him
it's like hey man let me see your hands
come over here and he's like yeah yeah
no i'm good i'm just doing over here and
the cop didn't pull his weapon
and that guy when that guy pulled on him
it's too late he shot him before yeah
it's just too late
it's a tough decision i'm glad that's
during the and that was during the day
and he followed the guy the guy was
walking i mean it's
it's a trip man you know and people you
know don't watch their dogs and you know
people have their [ __ ] dogs on uh
their pit bulls or aggressive dogs and
the police show up and you're talking to
one person the [ __ ] dog gets loose
the cop turns around and they shoot the
dog yeah they do and people are like hey
man you shot my dog but it's like that
[ __ ] dog if you if you go like this
and that pit bull grabs you by your
[ __ ] arm he's you're he's gonna lock
on you he's gonna tear your [ __ ] arm
we're gonna kill you
in san francisco when i was there there
was a dog that got loose that mauled a
woman who was just walking people don't
have their dogs on on leashes which is
incredibly [ __ ] dangerous and
everybody thinks that their [ __ ] dogs
are you know the best [ __ ] dog in the
world and they would never do this he
never acts like that i don't give a [ __ ]
about any of that stuff
you kick your [ __ ] dog your shoe
flies off that dog grabs your [ __ ]
ankle the the woman who owns the dog is
like going pepper leave them alone that
[ __ ] dog's mauling you to death i
have a daughter you have kids you you
know you your mom grandma whoever you're
out with man it's it's dangerous [ __ ]
and people think to think that they're
[ __ ] dogs like dl has that big ass
[ __ ] akita he travels with it's fine
for him but
i'm scared of a dog getting out of the
[ __ ] yard and you're right there and
he's running at you and the last thing
you hear is somebody say don't worry he
doesn't bite and this [ __ ] is
running right at you mm-hmm
right yeah i'm not going to understand
your words i'm just laughing because
there's a great scene
in a pink panther movie for peter
sellers there's a dog on the sidewalk
and some guy's walking by
and he says does your dog bite peter
sellers looks like don't my dog doesn't
bite and the dog comes and latches onto
his leg he says you said it didn't bite
he says that's not my dog
yeah yeah
wow that's good but we're talking about
in [ __ ] real life
people have all that [ __ ] right people
have all that are there what's the
liability there if a lady comes out and
[ __ ] nightgown the dog runs between
her legs and [ __ ] bites you across
the street putting your kid in the car
seat lucky dog
between that lady's legs and
you know it it it's easy rule of thumb
your dog it bites your problem
i don't care if it's on a leash or not
on a leash it's more more of a problem
of soft leash but even if it's on a
leash your dog bites it's your your
fault
you don't have total control that's what
the law says you have to have control of
your dog
so
[ __ ] dogs running at you what do you
do man it [ __ ] bites you what do you
do yeah i mean it's
not much
[ __ ] not much can they put up a fight
they just had a pursuit i laughed and
i'm not making fun of any police agency
but they don't use dogs as much anymore
because they got guns
there was there was a police pursuit day
before yesterday it lasted about three
hours
and i'm watching this thing and the guy
guy's racing all over town they block
him in he gets away they he was going
the wrong way on the five freeway
got off they blocked him in again and
all this was going brought daylight i
mean it's like three in the afternoon
and i'm watching this [ __ ]
and they finally get them all blocked in
with cars
and mexican dude and he finally decides
and he's not he's being belligerent
about everything
so he finally decides okay i'm going to
get out of the car but he's not doing
the hands in the air no what are you
going to [ __ ] and bam i mean from
here to the tv they're shooting them
with uh non-lethal weapons and a couple
of stun bags
and he he
he flinching and then so here comes
fluffy and they send fluffy in there to
bite his ass and the dog starts grabbing
his arm and trying to grab his leg and
he's fighting with the dog
pedro turns and runs away
and so the guy gets back in his car
takes off again
you know it was it was unusual so
fluffies don't even uh they're not
afraid of fluffies either
and and i've had guys
tell me where fluffy has bitten them
and they said man i'd rather be shot
than have that dog by me oh yeah yeah no
kidding i'm scared oh my god
it's
i don't know man it's a strange thing
because you know people have all these
dogs they might live in places that you
know aren't where people have them in
their yard or whatever man it's
dangerous yeah it's dangerous to for
kids walking home from school or
whatever you wouldn't want to lose your
kid because somebody
you know forgot that their dog was in
the front yard when they were you know
went inside to use a restroom or you
know went to look at their phone first
for one minute yeah it's dangerous [ __ ]
it's dangerous bad stuff oh yeah my dad
got his hand mangled once uh it was a
family dog like a distant family member
but he was going like hey puppy like i
had never had a problem before bit into
his hand like he almost lost a finger
just yeah nothing you can do you don't
can't expect it all right what do we
have today what are we doing
uh we got a bunch of voicemails oh but
the other thing you hit me about
beforehand astroworld if you wanted to
talk at all about that um
so okay so kyle rittenhouse so
now you see him on videos like saying
innocent as [ __ ] t-shirts and all of a
sudden he's like the [ __ ] poster boy
for
being a white guy getting off for
killing two people that's all the people
around him you know that's that
what should he be doing should [ __ ]
stay out of he should stay out of the
out of the limelight he should stay out
of the press but everybody's putting
them up it's not him there's no you know
everybody
should just leave the boy alone
if i were him what about his reaction to
the verdict did he think he was going to
be i mean i never seen a kid faint
before yeah he thought he was going to
be found he was just so excited i guess
i don't know you
faint he went down
uh like a sack of [ __ ] what about when
he hugged his lawyer and he said we did
it
what is that you're like we're i'm off
i got off right we did it we kept me out
of jail
i mean that's what i don't know what
they did with oj
and did it
that [ __ ] did it
oh yeah alleged i could say
i'll get sued he wrote legends
like that everything he didn't i would
allege the same thing
i was so disappointed in the burning i
couldn't even i couldn't turn on any tv
for two weeks
that was pretty heartbreaking man that
kyle
you know
when you when you're they make the
defender reach into a [ __ ] bag and
pull his own [ __ ] lottery balls to
pick out what kind of jury you're going
to have the [ __ ] is that and that judge
i think was not
a judge
the case never should have been heard in
l.a should have been held in santa
monica or no no the judge of kyle
rittenhouse was a judge oh that [ __ ]
judge was a
allegedly uh yeah from what i saw it
seemed like he was [ __ ] awful man
[ __ ] awful
and he was it appears that
he was down on the prosecution side you
know
he was chewing the chewed the prosecutor
out shoot him out in
court one day and
uh he was for the defendant he was for
on the defendant's side it appears it
appears that yeah that way
which but i've never seen a [ __ ] guy
a defendant look into a pull his own
[ __ ] jury numbers like what's that
the [ __ ] is that
i have no idea
do you see that [ __ ] no no no no
they're picking a jury and they're going
he's putting his [ __ ] hand into a
thing and pulling out numbers of jurors
what the [ __ ] is kind of [ __ ] is that
yeah i have no idea i have no idea how
they pick a jury pool here
well i don't think they they do it by
they do my computer the dodgers don't
even pick [ __ ] season ticket holders
like that put your [ __ ] hand in there
pull out a [ __ ] number of a juror
crazy let's see let's see what that guy
decides to do with uh with himself now
yeah because uh he's wearing an innocent
as [ __ ] t-shirt uh taking pictures with
uh with white guys in a bar and it
wasn't just like somebody gets drunk and
whacks him
that wouldn't you know
these guys are just
they get bitter they're different and
they walk to the beat of a different
drum
they may whack him
you can see well this is a podcast
shouldn't say anything
you could see somebody beating the [ __ ]
out of that guy yeah it looks like he'd
be easy to steal his lunch money from
not me because i'll get i get lost
coming over here i come over here
i'm gonna find my way over there in
kenosha keep circling the block
so that's it's pretty sad man it is
that's pretty [ __ ] sad and then
astroworld you know
with that with that concert that they
had
live nation and
and
uh travis scott and all those guys but
you know
um you put on these things where do they
cut first
they cut security security absolutely
security that is absolutely right it's
just bottom line they didn't have enough
people and that [ __ ] p people penned
in man when you go to a festival like
that you're not supposed to be you're
not like [ __ ] cattle surrounded into
a thing where you can't leave
you're [ __ ] in there people leaning
against the they're just squashed in
there i was watching last night the
documentary on tina turner
and she's at a venue
and i want to say
it was in italy or france or someplace
in europe
136 000 people
and it showed the crowd yeah an enormous
crowd
and they had to have everything
you know
in line they had to have enough security
they had to have set up and when they
tried to cut corners
they have a stampede there no they were
all right no no they didn't have a
stampede but that guy that guy you know
if you look at if you look at um
if you look at the history of a
performer
where you could see issues where
a guy came on the stage he stopped the
show guy was
had a video don't get out of here man
somebody tried to steal his shoe on
another thing in italy in europe he
stopped his show he said [ __ ]
tried to steal my shoe beat his ass
right there yes so he stopped the show
when it was something about him
but
you know that was uh
there's some there's some blood curdling
screams and
the music is so loud
and there's not anybody around that's
really you're not going to find you know
there's not a usher in the middle of
there saying something is simple what do
you do if you're in the middle of that
crowd you got a [ __ ]
well i mean you know you can't you
there's no place to go everybody's back
then
you know they had nothing prepared for
anything that's pretty bad
the uh the um
the lawsuits i think and then you know
anybody will sue for anything now yeah
so if anybody got billions of dollars
anybody got stepped on you you're gonna
take an opportunity to file charlotte
there's people who have lost those lives
which i mean i can't even imagine you
know your child goes to a concert and go
okay have fun but be careful they come
they don't ever come back
from a show from a festival you know i
mean i may file a lawsuit i was thinking
about going over there
yeah they would have just got on you and
then you know he sees the the golf cart
that's an ambulance and he says like
what the [ __ ] is that it's like he sees
the red and blue lights you know in
there yeah and he's on stage like how
the [ __ ] is that it's like a golf cart
slash
medic whatever but it's a it's a bad it
is and then what that situation there
people crashing the gate crashing the
gates
it's temporary fencing
yeah you know they're not gates they're
temporary fencing that's all it is
the uh
one of the performers
one of the big rap guys that was
performing with him
drake drake after the show
is in the news where he's dropping
million dollars with his
strip club
does it make him look good
no it doesn't
and then travis scott and kylie jenner
went to dave and buster's and had an
after party over there so you know but
they they're allowed to go wherever they
want but
uh this is that's that's a serious very
serious situation with
um
you know
the history of festivals and stuff like
that but
no security and bad and people penned in
and
you know all that stuff is
they haven't had problems you can't do
that locally we can't do anything [ __ ]
without anybody [ __ ] dying i think
coachella
has been going for a few years now they
they obviously have enough security over
there they haven't had the problems
because they just get drunk and wild i
think they learned a little bit from all
the other places i know the guy one of
the guys
created it but you know they get free
water out
you know when you get there and they
have big areas but no one is penned in
yeah that's a big thing
like you know you can only get so many
people in this room but if we did it
outside you get you know there wouldn't
nobody be penned in yeah i think in
trapping people into an area and people
couldn't get out that's the issue
is nobody could get out once you got in
because you know you're surrounded by
temporary fencing or whatever that is
but nothing
nothing personal intended but
who would think of taking their little
child to that thing because one of the
people that got killed was a little baby
yeah and that 14 year old kid but that
guy travis scott he he's in fortnight
he's in the gay i don't play fortnight
but he's in fortnite so he's got a lot
of young fans and then he's got the
shoes the dior shoes and he's got a deal
with mcdonald's so he's trying to get a
young audience so like that that father
said you know my son was a huge fan he's
nine years old but he sees him in
fortnight and you see him and all that
stuff but
i mean going to a show on a
nine-year-old i mean we everybody's got
to look at how would they put shows on
and and create
safer places like secure you know they
hired people to be security people of
that nobody knows cpr nobody has a
signal there i mean yeah it's pretty
dangerous it's it's cheap just gave him
a yellow shirt and you know and people
would go to places that
i think are
cheaper
ticket cheaper thing but not not safe so
i think also as people you have to
figure out where you're going to go what
you're going to do
and
what what are you willing to put up with
uh to do it like to go to go and see
that guy
or to go
sit there everybody has a phone and i
think you know that's when i started
looking at all the stuff on youtube with
that guy from memphis aka oh yeah ak-47
is this rapper there that southern man
crazy you know they say that our aura
they're like that dude like i've been
watching this guy trying to get him on
the trying to get him on the podcast
yeah and i sent him a couple mess on
instagram and they're they're like oh
man i can't believe that you know
because you know that from the shows and
all that stuff that they that that they
know me yeah and then i said hey man
come on the show man says oh i would
love to because
i just think that as southern as that
dude is his his mentality is
it's it's simple you know it doesn't
have to be complicated to be right like
it's it's simple but it's right
and you hear this guy talk and you're
like first when you get you get past the
way he speaks because he's southern but
what he's saying is [ __ ] is really
simple with rappers too like they almost
said like hey
if you're a rapper and you're wearing
this all this and you're in a [ __ ]
camouflage lamborghini and you're going
to this place to go buy cookies and
you're wearing a [ __ ] million dollars
in jewelry you gotta
you gotta have you gotta be safer than
that because you're gonna go back to a
place people are gonna resent you for
going back
and for helping people out
you know a guy got shot because his
grand somebody bought
robes for the choir and then the
grandmother said oh this dude bought
ropes with a choir and the other guy
said man [ __ ] that [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] shot that dude because it's not
about what it's about what he did and
it's like the grandmother said that that
that man was so kind he went and did
this for us and then that there those
guys are like man [ __ ] that guy he don't
come in here and buy that [ __ ] and they
didn't do it and then it's just man the
the value of life or the value of
somebody
[ __ ] their life up for the rest of
their life is just i mean like that sure
[ __ ] gone forever you know you're
gone forever and a guy is like on with
it with a
banging stacks a hundred dollar bills
together i only see taxes when i see
that much cash all like
even somebody says how much money do you
think that is all i see is [ __ ]
numbers should be paying taxes on that
it's half right there
he'd be banging if he if he paid taxes
he'd be banging
just a few little things to you like a
little stack
but they don't and they're out there
with that kind of lifestyle everybody
wants to live live that lifestyle and an
amateur rapper at a at a holiday
festival last night
had a fight with his girlfriend he's in
his car he drove through
a [ __ ] parade and
killed 12 people oh is that what
happened is that the guy with the red
that's another guy amateur rapper like
amateur whatever but everybody wants to
be a thug
i mean to get respect you don't have to
be a thug just be a law-abiding [ __ ]
citizen he's just sitting in his car
this [ __ ] parade's going on he's all
mad he's like man [ __ ] this he goes
through the [ __ ] parade and kills
people it's crazy and over there but you
know where i live they have this
festival of lights every year today it
starts on the 19th or whatever that the
[ __ ] day that is and it it takes four
hours to get through it so you have
bumper-to-bumper [ __ ] cars for a
month until after new year's in this one
area by this park if somebody starts
shooting in there you're bumping a
bumper where the [ __ ] are they gonna go
is that safe now that's what i would
think if a guy's in there and two guys
start beefing a guy takes a gun out and
you're in there with your car looking at
[ __ ] lights in a park
and the guy starts shooting you're not
going anywhere
so
you know in my old age
i think people have to be more
attentive of where they're going first
of all remember that time i told you
that that guy said to me don't ever come
back out of your garage always back in
so when the garage door opens you're
coming out head first that rapper over
there in memphis he he had his
lamborghini parked headfirst into the
store
and there was a guy with him that was
his security both he and his security
guard inside that cookie place were both
looking down at their phones when the
guys started shooting so by the time
they looked up they were done this is
yeah it's a young dolph you're talking
about yeah they're both in there
looking at their phones and by the time
the shooting started they had already
got i mean dolphin dolph was the target
he already got hit and then his security
guy ran out there and tried to shoot at
those guys he ended up getting arrested
by the police but
his job wasn't to be looking down at his
phone with dolph his job was to be at
the door looking to see if anybody was
going to come in excuse me you'll just
be a couple minutes let my man come out
you guys can go back in there i'll even
buy you food and all that stuff el chapo
in mexico when el chapo would go into a
uh a restaurant when he was on the loose
they'd go in there his guys would go in
there and go everybody in here let me
have all your phones yeah everybody give
me all your phones give me all
electronics they put them into a thing
he would go in there and have dinner he
would pay for everybody's dinner he
would leave and they'd give everybody
back their phones and he would pay for
their dinners because he didn't want
anybody in there saying guess who's in
this restaurant
and that's the way you know that's the
way they were doing
but everybody's trying to be
a mobster trying to be a thug trying to
be rich trying to show that you have
something and if you know a guy going to
buy cookies is
36 years old done and it's hard to
convince young people that there's
danger out there you know because they
think it's it's nothing if i was a young
person
i would want somebody to [ __ ]
convince me that there's danger out
there so i'm not [ __ ] 23 years old on
a date with my girlfriend and some [ __ ]
goes down and you look at her face and
she's scared and you try to go over
there instead of just saying to her
let's get the [ __ ] out of here take your
car get the [ __ ] out do whatever you got
to do to get out of there or see it
coming and say you know what we're going
to leave how come i i don't like the way
this [ __ ] feels trust me do do it for
you know i'm sorry i'll bring you back
another time but we're gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here instead of being there
when some [ __ ] goes down because nothing
goes down nothing just happens like
there was a car a young dolph at the gas
station somebody videotaped them he
didn't see it and they're and they're
out there like they're they're they're
tagging that or or uh you know following
that guy around that [ __ ] didn't just
happen in a vacuum they were [ __ ]
they were [ __ ]
guys driving around
at a camouflage lamborghini in memphis
in the south of you know some part of
memphis none of it's justifiable but i
wonder what it stemmed from because i
read somewhere heard on the news he had
been shot like about four years ago
let's shout out here at lowe's
renaissance on highland ah see
they got shot
so you get shot
why would you go back could you give
turkeys out
to the to the to the underprivileged in
memphis great that's a beautiful thing
you don't necessarily have to go to that
have have a church do it absolutely
don't go there for you yeah
in your name now you don't have to go
there
get that love you're in some jeans with
a million dollars worth of jewelry who's
not going to be tempted to do that [ __ ]
especially they see you on instagram
everybody's a thug everybody's got money
and girls oh man that's why i don't wear
my mr t look like there you go i know
i'll get you
i'll get you i'll get i'll get a shot
somewhere oh yeah i want to see you
coming with ice one day all right what
else
uh we still got some time for voices
let's go
all right
yeah cool you guys hit on some good
stuff too we actually have some relevant
voicemails for so uh it'll all come
together nicely
pilot the co-pilot
all right uh you guys ready
from the top
i wasn't born ready buddy
i learned damn got a
mouth in my throat what up george and
gil uh this question is for gil just
want to know man after working with
police and being a police officer so
long like how do you stop yourself from
being desensitized to bad people like
how do you still see
want to see people live after they've
overdosed or you know like
see people recover or rehabilitate their
lives even though they've been a piece
of [ __ ] for years and years and years
and you've arrested them or whatever
like
i see a lot of police officers that say
they show up and they'll let a dude
overdosing on heroin to let god decide
instead of administering administering
narcan and whatnot like um just how do
you stay in a positive mindset and not
become so sour in a profession that's
nothing but negativity
thank you
can i say that's a pretty good question
because yeah you know uh um
i remember i had a friend of mine that
was a police officer and he had some
pictures of crime scenes and he showed
us and we were like oh man a mess and he
was like this wasn't a big deal like you
get used to it but
um
i don't think the thing is to get used
to it is it
no you
number one you don't show all that [ __ ]
not to say that your friend was wrong
but
uh you don't show all that [ __ ] to
everybody that's that's not good you
know that's like spreading the
negativity
myself personally i just don't the way
i've survived is you don't dwell on the
on the negative
you look at the positive you know the
the end result is you're able to tell
some family member that we have the
person responsible for the death of your
loved one you don't dwell on what you
see everything is very scientific
like a gynecologist
looks at
yes private parts all day long doesn't
get excited but let him go out on a date
and now he's a regular human being
that's the same way it is we look at
that we don't see blood guts and guards
very scientific to us
and then
you just try not to dwell and you try
and forget about all the negative you
know the kids that you had to see or the
families you had to deal with
and you look forward to
associating with
good friends and having a good family
for support without family and friends
for support
you'd go nuts and that's why i had to
deal with it you know i think that in
this country in this world that uh you
know at a certain point when somebody is
alone
uh there's too many people in this
country that
are alone and lonely and whether they're
living
um with a lot of money he's still alone
or living in trailers or living in
apartments or they or the elderly are
alone and the end of their life is very
sad man like to be alone and to be an
elderly person is is
um
i mean it's really sad to see you know
you see them at restaurants and there's
or seeing places eating or somebody a
guy you know that's alone and all his
friends have gone home or however it's
tough to see people like that that that
you live a long life and there should be
a reward for that long life instead of
the the reward or or the end being they
find you after 10 days and you've been
in your apartment and you passed away 10
days ago
and now you know somebody says hey i
haven't seen that guy in 10 days and you
know he's in there alone what's that
ultimately it is and then it is sad and
that's what led me
i told you about a restaurant that we
used to frequent what's the name of that
place
no not not stephen this is casa alvarez
right there about my house
and there was a lady in there my wife
noticed elderly lady and she was by
herself she picked that up and no no
they hung down to her knees
and and so
my my wife just i was she's the one
she's the one that noticed and said look
at that the poor lady's eating by
herself
why don't you pick up the tap so we did
you know i picked up her tab i just
don't tell her after we're gone
so
we left and they explained to her and
next time i went in there she had a
drawing they said hey we got a package
for you
and it was something that she drew
and gave it to us and
i said well i didn't want no you know we
didn't do this again but she drew it and
she signed it so
thank her very much
we see her in there again
and i thought hey
here and i went over and i talked to her
and i said listen
i bought you we bought you that because
we just
felt compelled to do so you were here
wanted to have some company here you
don't have to paint anything you don't
do anything just we wanted to know that
we cared
and i left come back another painting
[ __ ] [ __ ] so
now
now we have to we won't go there at the
same time
nice lady but and i don't mind paying
for her but i just don't want any more
of her drawings
so that's hilarious
the [ __ ] out of here are you serious
yeah that's hilarious i'm not bad so
there were two lobsters that [ __ ]
crab is eating with her
before the crap dies he's going to get
full
so
that's all we're trying to do you
remember there are people
uh i i feel so fortunate i'm blessed i'm
surrounded by good people i have good
people
so that far outweighs the negativity i
should make fun of old people when i was
a kid
i still do i had no respect uh but then
now i'm an old person myself but but
also i wish i had i had somebody an
adult to teach me things like respect
for other people and things like that
when i was a younger man because i think
uh you know i have a pretty good heart
i've helped a lot of people i think you
don't you don't just become that person
but since i didn't have any really kind
of adult supervision or anybody that i
looked up to that you know i respected
that uh you know could mold me or guide
me
um i was a little meaner than i should
have been as a as a kid to people i
worked with a guy even had a big bet or
two but i was always by myself
i bet you a smelly one
that [ __ ] was awful
worked with the nicest mexican people
could smell it through my pants that's
when you know
my my brother was frank gonzalez with an
s because he was not easy he constantly
reminded people
and
he was just the nicest man i'd ever met
we were partners for five years i loved
him like a brother we did everything if
he saw frick frack's right next to him
we were always together well
he went to a death in the jail
and
the inmate died
and it wasn't that it wasn't a murder it
was natural cause death
so he contacted the living relative
and
it was his aunt
and she said that's the only living
relative i have she was an older lady
she was crying she was upset
he used to buy me my batteries to buy
this used by that
and he says i'll take care of you
and so he was started going to visit her
and then he told me one time he said hey
partner i need you to go down there with
me i said all right
so we go down to visit this list she's
in her eighties
and we go down there
no no not at all i have to ask but i sit
there and i go i go there in the world
one time i think they were big yeah i
think they were
and i go inside her house and it's an
apartment
but the air conditioner isn't working
it's leaking
and it smelled it was hot and it smelled
like urine not because she was urinating
just the stench from the wet water yeah
and it was terrible we had to buy her
ice cream we bought her batteries for
her hearing aid
and something else so she was living
like that right she was living and to
her to her i mean it's not
the
kind of place that you would want a
human being to be in no but it was just
that's how that's where her situation
was and her only living relative who
used to take care of her was now
deceased yeah so frank said i'll take
care of you and that's just the guy
frank gonzalez was
nicest guy in the world so he takes me
down there we go in there
and we're busy and it's hotter noel
digger's ass in there
stinks to hi heaven
and she says oh thank you for bringing
your partner i've been dying i wanted to
meet him so badly she's such a nice lady
and she says well i know you fellas
probably have to get back to work and
i'm sitting there saying yeah you know
we got to get out of here and frank says
no no no no no we're not in a hurry and
inside i'm sitting there saying were you
chicken [ __ ] why are you keeping me in
there and this stuff yeah so we finally
get out of the place
and i said frank
you know she's telling everybody in the
apartment complex that she's boning you
she's got this young mexican buck that
comes in there and takes care of her you
know
and all i ever did was make fun of her
and make fun of him yeah
and
he's such a nice guy
he would take he took his daughters
to visit so she would have a family
to look in
so
a couple years later now we're no longer
partners this is when i had transferred
out before i came back
i said partner whatever happened though
whatever her name was
and it says she passed away
i said oh and i felt terrible
i said partner why didn't you tell me he
says i couldn't tell you or sue coleman
because all you ever did was make fun of
me
and i used to sit there and tell hey
i bet you she'd look hot and some nylons
you know hooked up with garter belts and
everything for crit for halloween just
stick her out in your front yard put a
witch's hat on her it'll scare everybody
i used to make fun of him for it but
down deep inside
it it was so beautiful it brought tears
to my eyes
but that's how we had uh to deal with it
and he's just a beautiful person
beautifully
giving back to somebody nobody asked him
for anything
and he gave back that's that's what he
that's what he did he's a beautiful man
that's a good thing that's a
good thing to do my grandfather was
doing that to this old lady that taking
in her her
trash cans and stuff like that and you
know was he hitting it
did she have big nephew she did
she used to call him joe his name wasn't
joe but
everybody she would say hi joe
and my grandmother made fun of him for
that but um
and now you know i don't go over there
anymore i mean it's kind of where i grew
up but but we made fun of him for doing
that and
it was unexpected to see a guy like that
do that because he didn't really speak
much good english and she was kind of
old italian i mean she had to come from
about it and uh she was alone i think
she had a son or something but most of
the time alone and he went and helped
her i just which is
man you know a lot of people are leery
of even helping people yeah that's just
frank
i've never met a man uh nicer than him
he's a he's a great man yeah you know i
you know i went to el paso with all that
all that stuff happened you know
uh with the shooting in the in uh in
that walmart and
i didn't do it for publicity but
the and i hardly ever talk about it but
the thing that um
the thing that
i mean that kid drove from [ __ ]
dallas to el paso to shoe mexicans and
he let
other people who weren't
latinos run by him and he never really
went into the store
because he was doing everything from the
front of the store
and what made that guy stop shooting was
the actual the actual blood and what he
was doing made him stop shooting nobody
made him stop shooting he stopped
himself
because of what he saw
and
when i went there to go meet those
people and talk to those people
not one of them was tatted out neck face
tattoos nothing they were some people
from mexico
that came three generations and you know
not that there's good people or bad
people but we judge people but every one
of those
people that was in the hospital who was
affected by this guy shooting i would
have been proud to call a family member
myself and not one of those people said
[ __ ] that guy why us or how did this
happen george not one of them and not
any of the notes that were there and
that half mile worth of flowers and
notes and candles and everything
said like you know
made anybody out to be a victim like
that guy created victims but he didn't
shoot victims those people were
good decent decent people
and um
i
you know i you know
and i went back the two-year thing
and i try not to be
you know i think whatever people
for that particular time you know see
you as you know i come in the suit that
kind of kind of the way i always am and
then you're you're kind of protecting
your feelings and you might get
emotional and i spoke a little bit
didn't have anything prepared i didn't
wasn't planning on speaking but in my
heart and in my soul matt it's just
[ __ ] just it just hurts so much even
today
that
that element is out there and that
people target people by not
by whether you know them and they decide
to be good or bad people but just simply
by the way they look and that's not just
latinos just you know people rob old
people people follow other people people
want something that somebody has that
you don't want to work for and you know
in the society where there's filters and
you can make yourself look way different
than you are uh naturally and people
make you know millions of dollars as an
influencer and you're just you're
influencing people to live a life that
doesn't exist is is is wild in these
days man sure is you know and then that
what people find to be
uh of value and of of worth you know uh
is uh adulation or alike or whatever you
know the there's this family on youtube
called the ace family and they're
[ __ ] shysters man they're [ __ ]
criminals and thieves and they pimp
allegedly and they pimp their family out
and
they bought a 10 million dollar [ __ ]
house they were worth 20. warren buffett
lives in a 650 000 house and he has 115
billion dollars
you know i've been around people who
have billions of dollars and
they're not anything like the people who
are influenced the influencers want to
live a bigger life than people who are
[ __ ] billionaires on paper
multi-billionaires on paper
you know and it's just the wrong i mean
if it's like this now we'll be gone i'm
sure but where
what is it going to lead to man what's
going to lead you
when when
you know uh everything is i saw a girl
today walking down
the [ __ ] street or or a person you
didn't know what street you were on i
didn't know what street that's what i'm
trying to say but there was a little
chinito dude man looking at his
reflection taking selfies of himself he
had like a little [ __ ] palm tree
[ __ ] trying to make it look like
he was in hawaii he had a [ __ ] palm
tree
he had a [ __ ] palm leaf with him and
he's going like this on a sunny day and
you're like hey where you at why are the
[ __ ] over here in [ __ ]
summer
you're like what the [ __ ] man crazy
anyway so
on youtube mayan got me watching youtube
where i think youtube is more compelling
also the second season of tiger king is
is pretty good too oh is that already
out i didn't even know it's pretty good
my son just started watching he was
telling me that's pretty good if you
haven't seen tiger king you gotta
you know it's good to see white people
like that matter of fact we just
announced i i told him last night
i just heard him on the news or maybe on
one of the trailers
that they think they found her her
husband in costa rica alive
no
okay that that's a thing in the second
one but you know
because everybody
you know
i'm telling you i'm spoiler alert but
everybody thought that she fed that dude
to the tigers yeah yeah yeah that dude
had more [ __ ] going on he he would have
i don't know if they thought that guy
was a punk or whatever but that guy had
it going on and he would have never
allowed that woman
once you see what he was about to to to
take the upper hand on him
he disappeared because i don't think he
could trust her
and didn't want to be with her anymore
and she was one of those people like
let's be together forever and that guy
was like i got more [ __ ] going on over
here that i don't want you to know about
i'm gonna pretend i'm dead i'm gonna get
the [ __ ] out of here so maybe they did
maybe they did find it and joe exotic
that dude you know joe jotito right
there in prison oh yeah found some other
guy to be in love with uh from another
state somewhere so you know he thought
trump was i mean he thought trump was
going to pardon him and trump pardoned
[ __ ] rappers he didn't even know and
the fact that you know it's almost like
you know you can't pardon really kind of
what somebody was i mean i think
trump saw
joe exotic and probably thought i can't
i can't pardon him because they're gonna
we're the same person you know
if you like i yeah
i think
but but wild man you know wild about the
[ __ ] that you know you know when you
see carnival ride operators and you know
that they're at one church you remind me
of it and
a circus here in the valley next week
they're on the other side in southgate
next week they're in san diego and they
go around the united states
doing you know circuses and those are
those people
the guys that operate the riots
that's the old carney all right who else
well well hot damn uh we got time for
one more so let's do it one more i
didn't think i was going to talk that
much today but uh you know i did you're
doing good yeah yeah that's a lot you
gotta get in the entertainment boss [ __ ]
one balloon left of it
all right and actually along those lines
hey george just watching episode 36
right now 36 right now
you've never talked about where you
learned how to act i know you're in that
tv show
hilarious but never never knew where you
learned how to act from i know you're
started as a comedian and i just want to
know
where that transition come from comedian
to actor
is that a good question
um
well i mean
you know we just did that and we just
finished the amazon thing
where um was more dramatic like the
amazon the the
uh once upon a time in atlan where
i'm the father grand father grandfather
but i think that then to answer that
guy's question you know i said that uh
you know people complain about the lack
of
latinos in hollywood my show's almost
been on for 20 years i don't you don't
hear me bitching about that you know but
i think
if you want to be good at anything it
doesn't matter what [ __ ] color you
are you have to be prepared to to be
good at something and and
nobody's going to come and ask you to do
something
uh and if they do say hey you ever
thought about being in the show uh no
and then you can't act and they go away
whatever you want to do or whatever you
inspire to do you have to make sure that
you can get yourself to be
decent enough to where if somebody asked
you to act it's not unfamiliar to you so
you know once i realized way back 20
years ago that that i was going to have
an issue almost 20 years ago next month
an issue with with acting because nobody
ever asked me if i could act and i was
too busy preparing the show but once i
realized that
uh when i read the script with another
actor that i was probably the weakest
link that i decided to go get an acting
coach so you know now with youtube and
all that stuff somebody could take
acting classes or guitar classes or
learn how to cook and learn how to play
guitar or learn how to build a fence or
tune up your car or fix your
transmission all on youtube sure you
don't have to hire a coach anymore it's
all there but back then i would look at
movies of people that i like the way
they act and i would i would try to
see where
they were acting and if you know some of
the best actors you can't you can't see
them acting you don't catch them acting
and i think that so if anybody wants to
do whatever i would say you know
it's not going to come to you
and nobody's ever really kind of born
with that
much talent so you have to prepare for
that and then you know muhammad ali is
funny muhammad ali has that ken burns
thing on pbs
it's like four
um
multi it's like probably a 12-hour thing
and you know i always like muhammad ali
growing up and you know i remember you
know back then my grandmother [ __ ]
hated muhammad ali and then when he was
fighting joe frazier in their 70s that
we would go to sleep because it was like
you know they were fighting if it was
nine here's midnight over there probably
still fighting and you would run down
and get the newspaper in the morning
open it up and try to see you know who
won back then and uh uh i actually
always admired him but i mean when you
see
his life with things that you'd never
seen before in his life very emotional
man it's very emotional to me
uh uh to see him
and the things that he went through
because i always admired him but i never
seen a lot of those things uh and uh
yeah i found myself i didn't like him i
was always waiting for somebody to pee
that's all i wanted somebody to beat him
only because he was a draft dodger he
was a talker and he was a draft audrey
didn't want to do this didn't what and
it wasn't until later on
that i learned to appreciate him
and
he was a good man very special and he
was a very special man and and had a
brilliant uh he had a good sense of
humor
everything was going for him and uh
i became a fan it was tough to see him
get he thought he fought too long he
fought too long and his brother uh rudy
his name was rudy really named him after
rudolf valentino and his brother has i
think he still lives he may still be
living and he and he lived in uh
in louisville and he had parkinson's as
well and he he was a fighter but you
know you didn't hear about him as much
as you come back clearly brother ali but
yeah and then howard bingham who was uh
muhammad ali's photographer i met in the
mid 80s and then muhammad ali was the
grand marshal of the la um the marathon
and he invited me to go meet ali one
morning early and i didn't go
uh because uh
you know and howard bingham called me at
[ __ ] like 5 30 in the morning he was
just checking man you're coming and i
said man i think i'm gonna make it man
and i from san fernando i could have
gone to coliseum i was gonna come go by
myself at that time i was probably not
24 or 25 but you know there i you know
i've met so many people but i think i
would have
i think i would have
don't quote me on this but i'd be
willing to bet a month pay
muhammad
they've got a picture muhammad in big
gym at steven's steakhouse
he went there too muhammad was there
bring it home gail bring it home
frank sinatra muhammad ali
damn what is that place
it's there it's gold brother i'm telling
you we're going that's we're having the
anniversary of the oh my god hi podcast
you're just going to tell me give me a
date
please yeah yeah there you go
we'll get the place he's ready to do
whatever you want it's there
and we'll get the abroads to put on the
the what are they the alter the tube
tops
spandex for the night
let's go there we go all right we'll
keep leaving voicemails
818-533-1843 and uh see you guys next
week right yep sounds good to me
you